Dr Bjorn lomberg and I co-wrote the
article we are jointly about to present
to you recently for the UK newspaper the
telegraph where it was also published in
print and online
Dr lomberg Who runs a think tank in
Denmark known as The Copenhagen
consensus is in my estimation
the most reliable commentator on the
environmental stewardship front in the
world and he and his compatriots are
responsible for most of the ideas in
this piece but first a bit of an
introduction
what is environmental stewardship
it is a set of conceptions and actions
based on the idea that human beings are
part of the natural world not beings
foreign to it
and that we have a responsibility to
ensure that our short-term activities do
not compromise our futures by for
example compromising the viability of
the natural systems we all depend upon
but Dr lomberg is no careless activist
quite the contrary he has done more than
anyone else to examine the multitude of
problems that confront us on the
environmental front well simultaneously
taking into account economic necessity
the moral and practical responsibility
we have to provide people with for
example education opportunity
and security
Dr lomberg and the experts in his group
have conducted very careful cost-benefit
analysis of a number of projects deemed
by a variety of global leaders to be in
the world's best interest
and they have rank ordered such
approaches
by return on investment in other words
they have attempted to determine where
we might spend our money on improving
the lot of the poor to take a prime
example and do the most good in the most
efficient manner possible
and that efficiency far from being a
mere practical and cold-hearted
consideration
is precisely what increases the chances
that any good at all will actually be
done which is a very difficult thing to
manage and that simultaneously allows us
to do more good as we can serve more
resources to do so
the requirement for such an analysis
seems self-evident although it is rarely
done the utility of all spending needs
to be assessed regardless of amount
and that is particularly true when
billions or even trillions of dollars
are at stake and the fate of the very
economies that sustain us hang in the
balance
we are all confronted with a constant
story about the catastrophe that faces
the planet particularly on the carbon
front
it is simpler and in some sense more
immediately morally rewarding to reduce
the complexity of planetary management
to the need to reduce our so-called
carbon footprint but the plain truth of
the matter is that a multitude of
troubles beset us both economically and
environmentally
we therefore require people like Dr
lomberg to think about many issues
simultaneously to produce a plan and to
help us move forward in the most
beneficial manner possible
I would recommend
that those of you who are truly
interested in such things familiarize
yourself with his work you could start
with the smartest Targets in the world
which is a summary of The Copenhagen
consensus think tanks attempt to
prioritize our action and detention in
the world on the economic and
environmental front and with that we'll
turn our attention to the aforementioned
Telegraph article and discuss how those
who hypothetically lead us are failing
to save the planet at this year's U.N
climate change conference known as cop27
why 27 because this is literally the
27th time that such a group has been
convened and as you will soon see or
hear very little has been accomplished
and much time and money wasted in
consequence quote insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again and
expecting different results
this famous quote often misattributed to
Albert Einstein might very well become
The Unofficial motto of the U.N climate
change conference in Egypt the 27th
session of the conference of parties
so-called cop 27. Global carbon dioxide
emissions have kept increasing since the
world's Nations first committed to reign
in climate change at the Earth Summit in
Rio de Janeiro in 1992 despite dozens of
climate Summits and the global climate
agreements struck in Kyoto and Paris
this is the case once again in 2022 when
we will collectively set a new emissions
record while rich countries increasingly
promise Draconian cuts and then
generally backtrack as they import huge
amounts of oil gas and coal to save
their citizens from energy poverty as
they have done most recently to address
the current energy crisis most of the
future emissions will come from the
currently poorer countries in Asia and
Africa as they power their climb out of
abject poverty in the previous 10 years
the world has focused more on
remediating climate change than ever
before despite this we're not achieving
anything although no shortage of money
has been wasted and a surprisingly
honest review of climate policies the
U.N revealed a lost decade the report
found that it couldn't tell the
difference between what has happened and
a world that adopted no new climate
policies since 2005. consider that
all those climate Summits and grandiose
promises all that expense and trouble
no measurable difference whatsoever this
state of affairs is unsurprising
unfortunately because today's renewable
energy sources have two big problems
first they occupy a vast amount of space
often displacing nature replacing a
square yard of gas-fired power plant
requires 73 square yards of solar panels
239 square yards of unsure wind turbines
or an astonishing 6 000 square yards of
biomass one study found that the United
States would have to devote a land area
four times the size of the United
Kingdom to clean power to fulfill
President Biden's promise of a
carbon-free economy by 2050.
second and of even greater importance
the two Renewable Energy Technologies
favored by the vast majority of
environmental activists are intermittent
or unreliable solar energy simply isn't
produced when it's overcast or nighttime
wind energy requires a breeze we're
often told by Green energy boosters that
wind and solar energy are cheaper than
fossil fuels at best that is only true
when the wind is blowing of the sun is
shining on a windless Dark Night the
cost of wind and solar power Rises to
the infinite it is for such reasons that
it is deeply misleading although highly
convenient to compare the energy costs
of wind or solar to fossil fuels only
when it is windy or sunny
it is also important to note that since
all solar energy is sold at essentially
the same time when the Sun is up and
Shining its value drops dramatically
when solar reaches 30 percent market
share in California for example as one
study revealed it loses two-thirds of
its value
furthermore because modern societies
require 24 hours of non-stop power
backup is not optional and that means
Reliance on fossil fuels when there's no
sun or when as more sun and wind is
introduced more fossil fuel backups
become ever more expensive as they offer
their services for fewer hours to
produce the necessary return on Capital
and what it batteries
globally we have battery storage with
current capacity to store one minute and
15 seconds of the world's electricity
consumption and that problem will not be
ameliorated soon even by 2030 Global
batteries will only cover less than 11
minutes of the global electricity
consumption and all of this just shows
the problems with moving electricity
away from fossil fuel when Biden
promises ambitiously that all of
America's electricity will come from
renewable sources by 2035.
he is addressing the comparatively
simple part of the climate challenge
electricity constitutes just 19 percent
of total energy use
we're far further behind in developing
solutions for agriculture manufacturing
Construction
and transportation
of these the latter transportation is
most often discussed by
environmentalists and virtue signaling
politicians who insist that the solution
is already at hand
electric vehicles
despite massive subsidies however just
1.4 percent of cars globally are
electric and that number is not Rising
quickly
the Biden Administration itself
estimates that battery electric cars
will make up less than 10 percent of
total U.S automobile stock by 2050. the
scenario for the entire world is that
less than one-fifth of all Global cars
will be battery electric by 2050. we
should remember as well
that we simply do not yet have electric
tractors or heavy trucks or airplanes or
ships
and that means that all the fossil fuel
infrastructure that allows such
Machinery to operate will have to stay
intact for our supply chains to continue
their current necessary operations and
our turbocharged on electric cars will
produce very little impact on the
climate the International Energy agency
estimates that the world would produce
235 million fewer tons of carbon dioxide
if we achieve all our ambitious stated
transport electrification Targets in
this decade
the reduction
will lower global temperatures by one
ten thousandth of a degree celsius by
the end of the century according to the
un's own climate panels model tackling
climate change with current technology
is essentially impossible this means
that climate policy makers Tinker at the
margins offering deceptive Solutions and
moral grandstanding this pattern has
been repeated for three decades most of
the promises made in Rio de Janeiro in
1992 and in Kyoto in 1997 were
disregarded a 2018 study found that only
17 of the 157 countries that pledged
emission Cuts in the Paris agreement
passed laws mandating the required
action which nations Algeria Canada
Costa Rica Ethiopia Guatemala Indonesia
Japan North Macedonia Malaysia Mexico
Montenegro Norway Papua New Guinea Peru
Samoa Singapore and Tonga these are not
the Nations that will change Global
emissions even if every country did
everything promised in the original
Paris agreement the emission cuts by
2030 would constitute just one percent
of what is necessary to keep
temperatures Rising under the two degree
Target
failure however
has not made politicians or the people
they serve more careful
or more adamant about searching for
better Solutions
instead they we have doubled down making
ever more ludicrous but emotionally
attractive pledges despite zero chance
of either their implementation or their
success if implemented attempting to put
forward the much heralded and
off-trumpeted vision of a zero carbon
dioxide emission World whether by 2035
or 2050 would be so ruinously expensive
that extensive
style riots the kind we saw in Paris are
certain long before the goal is reached
the New Zealand government promised
carbon neutrality by 2050. they then
commissioned a report to estimate the
cost of doing so sequence of Affairs
that should perhaps have been reversed
the results even if implemented
efficiently the cost by 2050 will be 16
of total annual gross domestic product a
figure higher than that of the entire
current annual National budget
and that cost will be incurred every
year that's nothing but a pathway to
less prosperity and treading down such a
pathway will produce a host of secondary
consequences including serious civil
unrest that will not be in the least
beneficial to the planet
the renowned scientific journal Nature
recently published a study indicating
that getting 80 of the way to Biden's
promised climate Utopia by mid-century
would cost every American more than five
thousand dollars per year the same
Americans who are willing to pay only a
fraction of that about 177 dollars per
year according to research published by
the Yale program climate change
communication in the journal
Environmental Research letters getting
to a hundred percent would more than
double that cost it's no surprise that
hypothetically green-minded politicians
invents little enthusiasm for
investigating the true cost of their
Preposterous and self-serving promises
if we do care about fixing this
challenge we need to change course
pretending that the proper technological
answer currently exists and it's not
being implemented because we lack
conviction and willpower as Reckless and
misleading worse it stops us from
pursuing real solutions to the many
problems that confront us only one of
which is climate change dozens of the
world's top climate economists and three
Nobel laureates and economics recently
evaluated a whole gamut of climate
solutions for the think tank Copenhagen
consensus continuing to do what the EU
has been doing cutting carbon emissions
with a mix of market and planning
dictats means spending one pound to
avoid a mere three Pence of long-term
climate damage that's partly because
cutting CO2 output and the rich and
already efficient producing EU is
impractically expensive and partly
because EU climate policies are much
more inefficient than necessary the EU
prefers to use solar and win so example
to cut ton of CO2 over the more
efficient option of switching from coal
to Natural Gas the noble Laureate and
climate Economist instead determine that
investment in green energy Invasion
comprise the best long-term investment
why consider how the world worried over
starvation in the 1960s and 70s if we'd
approached that problem like we're
approaching climate remediation we would
have required the rich to eat less while
serving their leftovers to the poor that
would have failed as our current
approaches will fail disastrously what
worked instead the Green Revolution the
Innovative development of high yielding
crops we thereby increased World grain
production by 250 percent between 1950
and 1984 raising the calorie intake of
the world's poorest people and reducing
the incidence of serious famines
Innovative thinkers tackled the problem
head on instead of tinkering around the
edges Innovation meant producing more
with less instead of require hiring
people to make do with less would be and
even genuinely looming catastrophes have
been continually pushed aside throughout
human history because of innovation and
technological development it's
Innovation that gave us security and
prosperity and that continues to drive
the growth and the increased efficiency
of the world's largest economies in
general unfortunately investment in
long-term Innovation is underfunded
because it is hard for private investors
to capture benefits in areas where
long-term Innovation on the private
front can be underfunded because of the
difficulties in monetizing benefits in
the sufficiently short time frame public
investment and support is often
warranted
a recent example and a stellar success
on the climate Innovation front
the 10-year 10 billion dollar U.S public
investment in Shale gas which originated
under President George W bush
remarkably this endeavor was not planned
as part of the policy of climate change
remediation
nonetheless it led the way for a
production surge with all the attended
economic benefits particularly for the
poor that allowed natural gas to become
cheaper than the dirtier coal it
partially replaced
energy derived from natural gas
produces approximately half the carbon
dioxide of coal
the consequence the U.S
has the best record of carbon dioxide
emission reduction of any country in the
past decade and simultaneously reduced
its Reliance on foreign suppliers of
Uncertain reliability and cost everyone
in principle agrees that we should be
spending much more on R D however the
fraction of rich countries GDP actually
invested into green r d has halved since
the 1980s why
putting up inefficient solar panels and
wind turbines offer the opportunity for
good photo ops and allows those who lead
to convince us of their dedication to
action while funding researchers
requires a more subtle and mature
understanding and approach we might
remember however when considering such
things that our economic stability and
opportunity is now at theory of risk and
where simultaneously not currently doing
the planet any favors according to the
Copenhagen consensus Noble alert we
should increase our current spending
five-fold to 100 billion dollars per
year
this doesn't mean that in total we
should be spending more we already
devote 600 billion dollars per year to
finance ineffective climate remediation
strategy
we could instead take a mere sixth of
that poorly spent money and direct it
towards the most effective means of
addressing our problems
world leaders on the sidelines in Paris
in 2015 draw a billionaire
philanthropist and promising to double
green energy r d over a five-year period
the so-called Mission innovation did not
materialize spending as a percentage of
GDP hardly moved since then a genuine
innovation-led response would require
the consideration of multiple Solutions
we could improve today's Technologies
rather than erecting currently
inefficient turbines and solar panels
we could devote more attention to
nuclear fission perhaps in the form of
modular reactors and continue to explore
Fusion hydrogen generation from water
and more
the geneticist who spearheaded
development of the first draft sequence
of the human genome technological tour
de force completed far earlier and at
less cost than originally estimated
makes a strong case for Research into LJ
that produces oil grown on the ocean
surface
because such LJ simply converts sunlight
and carbon dioxide to oil when producing
it burning it would be carbon dioxide
free
oil algae are far from cost effective
now but researching this and many other
Solutions is not only inexpensive but
offers our best opportunity to find real
breakthrough Technologies
if
we innovate the price of green energy
down below fossil fuels
everyone will switch this would be a far
better solution particularly for the
poor then increasing the cost of fossil
fuel to the point of General penury to
disincentivize use
the Copenhagen consensus experts
calculated returns from Green energy r d
at 11 pounds for every pound invested
hundreds of times more effective
than current climate policies
finding the breakthroughs that will
power the rest of the 21st century could
require a decade or it could take four
but no other genuine Solutions beckon
and we've already had three decades of
spectacular failure pursuing the
policies that are currently in place
we know that the world leaders gathered
at cop27 won't solve the problem that
passettes with the same empty promises
offered 26 times previously
are we going to do the same thing yet
again remember the definition of
insanity but Innovation beckons as it
has so reliably in the past we have
better options and ignore them at the
cost of our economy our opportunity and
the environment
[Music]